hey guys now this is another video
request
some of you asked me daniel what are the
correct ways
to roll up my sleeves and when should i
do it what kind of situations
so in this video i'm going to quickly
show you the wrong and the right ways to
roll up
your sleeves let's get to it
i have a dream that's all i need all
right guys now let's get
right into this never roll up your
sleeves like this
or this it looks terrible and
sloppy i just quickly had to get that
out of the way now that that
is out of the way the wrong ways of
rolling up your sleeves
let's move on you can roll up your
sleeves at any time when you feel
too hot or when you eat messy food
or any other situation that requires you
to do so
now rolling up your sleeves sends a very
strong
message saying i'm ready to work
and i'm a go-getter and you can also
transform your look
from formal to more casual
now of course there are times when it's
better not
to roll up your sleeves like at a super
formal event
or an important lunge with your boss or
a black tie event
you get the picture right now let's look
at three stylish ways that you can roll
up
your sleeves some people make this too
complicated and it's not
it's just you rolling up your sleeves
and the easiest and fastest way that you
can do it
is the forearm roll and some guys call
it the eye far roll but let's keep it
simple the forearm roll you just roll it
up twice
about the width of the cuff and that's
it
casual and simple showing your forearm
next up the basic roll it's pretty much
the same
as the forearm roll except you roll it
up once twice
three times four times as many times as
it requires
to go above your elbow and lastly
and my favorite most stylish way to roll
up my sleeves the j
koorol first roll up about two widths of
the cuff
second roll again to the bottom of the
cuff
and lastly roll it the last time leaving
the top
of the cuff exposed it looks stylish and
it won't easily get
undone now if you want more style tips
or anything else on fitness grooming or
life itself
then check out one of these videos here
and i'll see you there cheers guys